Then he realized that his friends were
telling you stream just stopped our
recording for some reason.
All right man.
I'm probably the fucking man and now
it's back on him man.
Ladies Gentlemen.
Refresh your browsers.
People.
The man.
Apparently it was just fucking.
That's crazy.
Like it just went off air and then
everything came back on by itself.
Yeah,
he took it with his friends.
Does he want to be a Downer because
they're all taking is you utopian story
smokers.
I got fuck it.
But he didn't feel anything so like all
right.
But then he didn't want to be the one
left out so I was like,
fuck it.
I'll smoke with you guys.
He would pass it and he was like,
take some.
And then he realized he could for the
first time,
like years and years could actually sit
there with those legs and arms like
cramping.
Got Sean Rouse.
Maybe it could help them.
I don't know that there's no way that
guy does not smoke pot.
No,
no it doesn't.
That doesn't smoke weed.
You would think that doug would smoke
weed.
Stan?
Hope does not.
Like we'd really.
He's done a few mushrooms,
Stan hope we did DMT.
He'll go to other dimensions like pop
banks and paranoia and isn't like the
negative side effects of everything for
everybody.
The paranoia that pot gives you is
really.
It's almost like the opposite of alcohol
because alcohol makes you look through a
tube.
Alcohol.
You like looking at the world through A.
Yeah.
To seeing marijuana's the opposite.
Marijuana,
like your blinders.
I see it in front of me,
Brian.
It went off and on for a second.
It blipped today.
Just so you guys know.
It's not me.
Fucking it up.
Use Dreams just fucking operate.
If you can't see red band,
he's actually speaking into the
computer.
You can't blame Brian.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't be mean.
This is difficult to figure out the
stupid shit out.
Ultimately,
I would love to have this on my website,
on Joe Rogan Dot Knapp,
but right now I don't think the
technology's available.
It's not quite ready,
but this is ideally the best way to do a
show.
You know?
This is way more fun and doing some some
show that's on television that nobody
gives a shit about,
you know,
I mean this is what we can do.
Whatever the fuck we want.
You don't have to look at it.
I don't want anything from you.
No one's getting paid just for fun,
you know,
and you have interesting people over and
you talk and write.
How many times have you done,
what's the matter Brown girl blaming me,
Brian,
Brian and the cone in and like a talk
show and it's like you prepare for it.
It's like a big deal and then you sit
down and talk to someone for like seven
minutes and you're like,
I didn't even say anything.
Did we get to talk about anything?
I mean I had a few topics that kind of
got out of the way a little bit,
but barely 70 thing.
And then in every one of those shows are
set up for that reason that it's just
nothing.
You just leave there going,
I that was nothing.
Anything I didn't even know it was a
great appearance.
Didn't say two words.
It's like if you're a Chelsea handler's
show the those guys down there say like
four or five words and then you're done
and then they're done.
Yeah,
it's
real weird.
And people go,
Oh,
you're a great.
And that's what they want.
Short attention span,
Bang,
Bang.
See this guy real quick.
But I mean,
but that's,
that's the if you want to go for like,
if you want to go for like the APP,
you know,
just just a shot in the dark with
people.
That's what you should give them.
You should give them the shortest,
quickest,
little things as fast as you can so they
don't lose interest.
What do you do?
You want the people that lose interest,
that easy to pay attention to,
you know,
know doing a numbers game because.
But then again,
I mean how many times have you seen a
youtube clip and you start to open it
up,
you and not enough minutes.
You're like,
fuck,
I don't even want to start over all
those people,
but that's a youtube clip is totally
different than something like this.
You know,
this is like cool because you can throw
this on at work,
you know,
and you're doing some boring fucking
thing at work.
You could throw this on and watch it
while you do it and just enjoy a bunch
of people hanging around talking.
I liked doing that.
I like watching fucking soldier.
Boy.
You know soulja boy.
Yeah.
I like watching him because he's having
a good time.
I like locked in that girl on that
train.
Do you see that video with the girl on
the train singing harshly singing
soldier boy at some old lady.
Just not.
That has nothing to do the story,
but they'll just say that.
That was a video that somebody put the,
the uh,
subtitles to understand what you just
said.
I like watching that kid.
You know why?
Because he's,
he's like 19 years old.
He's worth some fucking insane amount
of.
He's got diamonds all over his bias
himself.
Tattooed his fucking face,
tattooed his neck,
his arms,
his chest,
everything.
And every video that I watched is
talking shit.
Dancing and freestyle rapper,
talking about haters,
talking about other girls.
He's cluck and talking about how the
money he had,
how much money he has and how pretty is.
I enjoy the fuck out of it.
I really do it.
It's entertaining as shit,
man.
I was sitting the type of program that
would follow your brain so you can look
at everything you searched in one.
That's next dude.
That's because we're the next twitter.
It just shows you like show people what
you're thinking and watching where you
could search.
Well,
I somehow went from IC.
I started looking up fights or something
on youtube and then I found that fight
scene from the movie bodyguard from way
back in the eighties and somehow my
brain got from there to where I was
watching a riding dirty.
The song all cut to star trek wrath of
Khan.
So it was all clinical con was riding
dirty.
Know How my brain even.
How do you might want to watch this
clip?
Some something.
Conan said something funny and Leno and
then you cook that in.
Next thing you know,
I'm on soldier boy and you have a
wonderful time to go on youtube rods and
I go on porn rides to where you start
out normal and next thing you know it's
big dicks and Asians.
Blowjobs yeah.
Real specific.
Yeah.
And then you're typing stuff.
That's what it's wrapped.
My first video you watched that night.
It's just to grow a big tits.
Blowing somebody.
Yeah.
That's Kinda hot.
And then how did I get to find funding?
Yeah,
that's really kind of one of the
craziest things about porn on the
Internet.
Like Mozart could just anybody from the
computer directly goes to it.
There's no stopping it.
You can go right to a tick on an
asshole.
You don't have to pay,
you don't have to subscribe.
And that's what they sensitize.
People do it so much there.
So they see girls are taken in the ass
all the time.
Well I saw one of the porn sites,
they had like a comments section
underneath the thing.
So where people are complaining about,
Oh that girl looks speed on that girl.
And maybe because I'm older,
like whatever happened,
just being excited.
You were seeing porn.
Now you're.
No,
now they're so desensitized.
I'm going to judge that chick.
Can't always judges chicks.
These are professional hot chicks now.
I'm a judge.
Even back in the eighties,
I had my favorites.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Misty rain.
How can do professional porn anymore?
I have to have an amateur.
I have to have it on a cell phone.
I have to have it really happy to have
it fake.
If I see a flash bulb go off in the room
like,
fuck,
this simulates you,
your field.
This is really two people like each
other.
Our coaches are having real sex because
chicks just like looking at her watch
porn site for people who like each
other.
Just her pussy just beat the.
I don't want to.
There's that.
There's a whole genre of porn that's.
That keeps porn.
People like each other and it's not a.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We like that.
It's a little bit.
No,
girls will be fucked.
I just want to ask generally,
are they looking for.
You're not really.
I just want to know like it's real and
getting spit on and slapped in the face.
It's a lot of that man you like to do.
I'm like,
I don't like watching it.
I didn't expect them to tell the story
please.
She's like,
hit me,
hit me.
And I was like,
all right,
and by the end I was fucking boom.
But the follow through on the backhand.
Awesome.
I bet you her face,
she took it.
I don't know.
She didn't believe.
Didn't open her up.
Oh my God.
What?
You even paranoid that I would think
too,
that the girl would then go,
oh thanks.
Yeah,
this guy just knocked me around in.
You've got to think of a trip so crazy.
She wants you to beat her up.
She goes,
yeah.
And then what are you going to say?
She wanted it.
I mean,
I might also,
you should look at her ass fucking read.
Horrible,
terrible thing,
but.
So is pretending you've been raped.
I mean,
how many
people have heard stories?
Girl gets mad at a guy and just decides
to tell people that he raped her.
I had a friend who worked,
worked,
he played for the Detroit lions when I
was in Detroit,
and that happened to me.
It was the two girls back at his place,
Super Nice Guy.
The one girl jokingly said,
you know,
what we could do is we could say that
you raped us and well,
how much money would we get?
And they were like,
she said it as a joke,
so immediately said,
let's go knock on his neighbor's door
and said hey,
whatever.
Meet my two friends that.
So we'd have one other person to see
their condition when they left.
So they couldn't that make up the story.
And I had another famous friend,
he would,
every time you hook up with a girl in
the room,
he was like way famous.
He'd go to the front desk girl,
he'd walk out,
that girl,
whoever was there,
he would stop.
So talk to that person.
So there was one other person I'd see.
She didn't run out all disheveled,
like what just happened,
just as a backup because you were
honest.
I just want to go to bed and be like,
see you later.
You know to a lot,
I mean to a lot of people,
people that are like famous,
some famous rockstar or something like
that.
That person is there.
So unfair there situation.
It's so unfair how much more they have.
How much.
Yeah.
How much better their life is so unfair
that people feel like you owe them
something.
Like you've got an unfair amount so that
try to take from you.
So there's a lot of people that don't
even feel bad about like fake lawsuits.
They don't even feel bad.
Yeah.
Chapter,
which man,
fuck the rich and you make that money.
If someone got fucked over,
run over my foot the other day,
play back the video.
He did get hit by the car and he was
just trying to pop.
Razzies ran.
I was thinking of like have some kind of
thing.
We hit one button and you zap all the,
all the computers that are around you,
they have this
laparotomies.
It's the same thing.
They're just a bunch of people that are
making a living,
doing something negative and they don't
need to do that sort of negative because
a lot of times they call those people
and I'll be at the front,
the girl after them.
There's a lot of people that like it,
but when you're chasing someone,
someone's upset with you,
like they have their kids or something
like,
like Dr drew,
but by the way we were talking about Dr.
Dre has stats on pause,
retarded,
but he's a really nice guy.
I've done is show,
uh,
the um,
the loveland show and he's,
I've met a bunch of times.
He's a really cool guy and he told me
that he was in Hawaii and the,
uh,
the,
the fucking pop around taking pictures
of his,
if his kids,
him and his kids.
Well it was worth something that they
make money,
man.
If you get it like a juicy picture.
How about that picture of John Travolta,
kissing that dude's somebody got paid
for that?
How bad was it?
I saw one of the lips.
I freeze frame kiss.
It'll never look like a casual.
It's awesome.
I love how John Travolta rocks a
fabulous wig,
you know,
and just.
Yeah man is some pictures.
He's balding and other fisheries is get
the best head of hair ever.
Wow,
that's awesome.
The TMZ,
I saw one of the guys who works on Tmz
and one of the guys so we saw so and so
at the airport and I wanted to go up to
them so bad with the camera and just
sticking it in his face and ask some
dumb questions and I probably could have
sold that back to Tom because I wanted
to do as a sketch that will do it.
Just go fucking guy that does tmc.
Can he handle left 15 minutes show
without taking a drink of water because
he has like his sippy cup that there's
no one that's watched.
It's evil because those guys are making
fun of people that are on tv yet every
one of them wants to be so
famous and is enjoying all the fame
they're getting from being on the show.
But that's legitimate too,
because some people liked the way the
bitchy,
like they wish they could be that bitchy
and they liked watching them.
It's like a form of energy.
A lot of what the Chelsea handler show
is to shit on people where you wished we
could work with.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
But you know what,
there's a place for that too.
It's the same thing as like rich people
that get upset at,
at poor people.
It's like people are not famous.
They like and pick out going after
target woods,
you know,
go find him.
He's got a billion dollars.
Fuck him.
Like some woman actually said this on
the Jimmy Kimmel show.
Uh,
she was uh,
running a website where people could
find people's houses and,
or no,
no,
it was um,
you would say where the celebrity is at
any given moment and understand that
there's like stockers and this can be
dangerous.
And she goes,
well,
I'm,
I'm sure that their sleep well on,
on,
you know,
all their money,
like a bag full of money.
And it's was like,
really?
That's how I look at it.
Like if you're willing to put the Poles.
Yeah,
put people.
Especially young girls like,
you know,
some dudes get fucking really nutty
about young girls.
Like they get crazy.
Like that one girl that got shot,
it was like when I first came to
Hollywood,
some girl got shot.
It was on a of shocker even
understanding how a black hair,
she was really pretty.
It was like a childhood,
not childhood star,
but like 22 year old.
She become famous when she was like
young and some dude just got obsessed
with her,
found out where she lived.
She opened the door,
he shot her in the chest.
How scary.
Like stock,
because out when I used to do radio in
Detroit,
this girl within me,
15,
16 page letters,
not one piece of white left on the
paper.
So it was written sideways anyway about.
I had fun going out with you looking for
houses.
Shit that never happened.
You know,
I heard about your secret messages that
are not.
And then she went away and then she came
back and every time I'd be in Detroit
she would leave these letters.
When your life's gone and it's just us
and you know,
crazy stuff.
So I went to go get a restraining order
against her because she was showing up
at my shows and what we'll find out
where I would be in the judge.
What
did you fuck her?
No,
no,
no.
I just trying to think how far back was
this.
Yeah.
No was it
was uh,
it's been about 10,
15 years and the guy wouldn't.
The judge would not get what she wanted.
He wanted to hear her side of the story.
Now I had a stack of papers this big of
her saying she came to the radio station
I worked at with some of my stuff.
She goes,
John Leftists.
It was an empty can of tuna fish.
Whoa.
Junk mail and baby shoes.
Then she got to your house.
Well,
no,
this was from her place I guess.
And then I had stacks of letters saying,
I hear the secret messages that you're
giving me.
I will respond to them.
When you say this,
it means this.
But when you go to file a restraining
order,
the judge,
you get less than a paragraph to write
why you don't get the hand in any of the
psycho stuff.
So that.
And then he saw that and then the guy
who did it for him,
he goes,
he's a dude,
he probably thinks you're a pussy that
you can handle the.
Just know that because I'm a guy and I
had this girl stocker.
The judge thinks that,
yeah,
it's like you're a pussy,
you're a guy.
Handled the girl.
Don't bring us involved.
It was his attitude.
So I,
I couldn't,
I couldn't find it.
It was the judge's attitude.
That's what the.
And you know that long ago,
that was before that checkup.
No,
this,
this.
I tried doing this.
I tried this a couple of years ago,
but it doesn't a year ago,
but it doesn't apply to California.
So I go through all this work,
get it done in Michigan.
They come out to California.
It doesn't mean anything.
You've got to refi one in California.
She,
she dropped flies in Texas to see you.
Doesn't matter.
Now you have to file one a texting
really,
and I'm a so I couldn't imagine you put
this information on.
Yeah,
yeah.
Hey,
Brittany Murphy,
the actresses just died.
Her mom and her husband has been doing a
tour and all the talk shows and I got to
catch it today on the today show.
It's how fucked up your daughter just
died and they're fucking,
they're just sitting there like for no
reason not promoting anything.
We're trying to do anything but just
like I've seen them on like four
different talk shows in the last line.
It was weird,
but they do it for money and they do it
just to like the people attention or
whatever.
It's only about the daughter
versus like him coming up.
We have pretty Murphy's moment and
Brittany's Murphy Murphy's mom just
sitting there and she knows the camera's
on.
She goes,
oh.
And it was,
oh no,
no,
no.
You find it on Youtube or Hulu or
whatever.
And it is disturbing to watch.
Like it was so gross in a husband with.
So what was the accusation?
What does the sterile.
No.
Well what's the.
Isn't there like a current drugs,
but then they said,
but there just wasn't time
ids or something like that.
That was when she was yelling.
I don't think it was a weird situation
at all.
Really.
It just came up.
She was showering is talking about
heroin and other that
I still don't know yet,
but that's kind of weird that.
Well it's kind of weird or what,
but it's the kind of with the husband
did want an autopsy?
Yes.
And if a 30 year old person dies,
you want to know what the fuck happened?
I'm Jewish.
Other he doesn't look Jewish.
One,
it's against religion.
It's against your religion basically.
What happens if you murder a junior?
That's fucking crazy.
That makes it easy to murder.
You guys.
Synesthetic haven't thought this out to
our bodies.
We can get them on your body's.
Yeah,
but you can't give you an autopsy,
but because I just read this poison
that,
but now they're not going to know
suicide naked.
Choke himself the last.
That's the story.
I'm sticking to it.
Yeah.
No autopsies.
I think there are certain.
Yeah.
Situations where they say if they're
afraid,
it might be like a generative.
Is that a word?
Heart disease for like the kids should
know that she got treated
or congenital congenital,
I don't know,
but they still offer that,
but not just randomly to figure out what
the cause of death is there.
Like he's dead.
Anytime a young actress dies and there's
medication around automatically do it no
matter what.
Whenever somebody says don't waste the
money,
commodities,
depressive,
change the topic.
Hey,
do you guys like cats?
What do you think about Oprah?
She's so generous.
No,
I'd have to go give a shit about me.
Somebody asked me for Paparazzi chasing
me.
They would make $0 of my pictures.
There's no benefit and taking pictures
of me.
You have to stay just under that level
of fame.
You have to stay in the level of fame
where nobody gives a fuck so you could
still work and you know,
you don't have to worry about your bills
and you can go out to dinner,
but you don't want to
fucking crazy at the Vince Vaughn wild
west comedy tour like premier and then
there's a part like across the street at
some hip club,
whatever,
Hollywood.
And uh,
so we leave and all the popular out
there waiting for Vince Vaughn and
Justin Long and stuff.
I'm running these degenerates,
you're fucking piece of shit,
you know,
it was like giving it to them and they
were like,
Hey,
the guy from parks,
he goes,
oh,
hi.
Yeah.
No,
that's funny.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
You know,
you can't go to places like,
you know,
who's the best sustained now?
That shit went in controversial life.
You consider them Mark Walberg.
Okay.
Was never on the tablets.
He's a giant movie star stars in
gigantic blockbuster movies and yet he's
never in the tablets.
That's amazing.
You don't know who else and he never
does interviews.
Nicholson.
Yeah,
just away from everything.
It's like,
well,
they would always catch him doing
something creepy,
shirt off at some beaches looking legs,
bloated,
fucking scared.
He's,
he's still like in seventies,
rocking it with 20 year old checks.
It's awesome.
It's really crazy.
Nicholson.
Like he,
he'll like,
you know,
they did some interview with them real
recently.
We were talking about the different
dates.
He goes on and you know,
one night we'll go out with a woman
that's in her sixties and nights,
nights and those are twenties.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean just,
you know,
I was,
he was talking about sexually who's
talking about friends,
you know,
like the,
these acquaintances that he has a very
varied life,
but you know,
you gotta appreciate that.
Yeah.
Dudes getting 20 year olds and he's
fucking 70.
That's how bad ass he is.
That's pretty crazy,
right?
He's defined nature,
whether it's fame and with his ability
to pretend
that overcomes the natural to pretend
and jog and unnatural done with sex.
Like that's not.
Yeah.
Well a companion his age,
especially if there was
no viagra.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean if there's no Viagra that would
take a lot of dudes out of the game.
It took a lot of dudes out of the game.
A lot of old rich dudes be like,
what's the fucking point?
You know,
but right now they can,
you know,
Brian Holtzman had to joke about that
because know I looked at because now
these young ones
of course have to fuck these old men.
And he goes and that is that sperm is
like paint that's been in their basement
for like a year.
You know that paint work and it's not a
fresh product.
Lead is hilarious.
It's not quite color picked out.
He's one of those.
There's a few dudes that over the course
of a month doing standup comedy that
I've,
I've always gone,
how the fuck did that guy not make it?
He's one of them,
right?
Yeah.
He's so good.
So funny.
Brian Holtzman,
if you're ever at the comedy store in
La,
that's where Brian were,
where it works out.
If you call the comedy store called the
comedy store and asked when Brian Holtan
was going to be up,
especially if something goes down the
news,
like I guarantee you he's got some fuck
up five minutes on Haiti right now.
Oh No,
but you'll laugh at any way.
I had always heard about.
He did this thing on Oj,
but it was like amazing.
One time he tried to do it again and it
wasn't quite as good as just an awesome
set about that.
And then a nine slash 11 happened and
Mitzi wouldn't put him on because we're
close.
Happened to that were closed Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday.
Just know.
And then we opened up Friday,
Saturday.
She knew that he would get up and talk
about it.
So she made the talent coordinator call
him and say,
listen,
we can't put you on.
I'm sorry,
but she doesn't want to.
He's one of those guys that would take
the opinion most fucked up by default.
He would automatically like go after the
victims and
do wrong.
Why were you in that building?
What will you do with it?
Just like his take out of it will be so
fucked up.
He went on Sunday though because open
like an open night and uh,
he did about 50 to 55 minutes and it was
maybe one of the best I've ever seen.
Standup was there watching standup said,
I disagree with 95 percent of this,
but it's so fucking goddamn good because
he's so crazy.
His stance was fuck the cops.
It goes,
but they're not heroes now.
Why?
Because it did the job one time because
I wasn't on the belt.
People jumping out of a building.
I went to a fucking cop was below me.
Take him out to nine,
15,
whatever.
Everyone's like,
what are the crowds doing?
These sheets.
I don't remember.
Oh,
you remember when that shit drowned.
Her kids know.
Yeah.
Wholesome.
It goes on onstage like three days after
his kids.
He goes,
ladies and gentlemen,
I had those were bad kids or a day.
Never put the blocks away.
They sat that close to the TV.
They always in their fucking milk.
Those kids will not be missed.
I went,
oh my God,
it will all I like to say they were bad
kids.
That's one of the most brutal and funny
just people's brains and comedy is
geared to like,
is it in my brain?
Just,
you know,
it's weird how you fall into whatever
style of comedy.
Like I would never even think about on
things,
but meanwhile he's really friendly.
Like if you talked to him like offstage,
like he's not a dark guy at all.
He's very nice.
He used to always go get me a coke when
I was working the color Blue Coco
classic from the back.
Go back,
go during a bug.
I'm going to start,
dude.
He's the faculty sometimes to Izzy goes
off sometime.
I had to find out when he's playing and
go perform.
Yeah,
and he was always so cool.
The fact that sometimes he was always
such a nice guy.
There was one time when I got banned for
Pauli ban me for like a weekend.
Most of them was so,
so nice about it and what,
what said Damn me for a weekend for
what?
I got mad at him because he got mad at
him and dean tried to corner me about
something and I told him he was a
fucking idiot and that,
you know,
he doesn't appreciate the Comedians,
that I'm not working for him.
It's one right after,
uh,
the uh,
minding the store came out.
It was,
it was like he all of a sudden was
running the comedy store.
It was all of a sudden,
you know,
it wasn't,
it wasn't like just a TV show anymore.
Now he was.
Because the comedy store we've always
done for free,
you know,
I always,
not only did I worked there for free,
but I don't all the,
when they had,
when they were giving me checks,
they gave me like thousands of dollars
with the checks.
I never cashed him because I always knew
that they were hurting for cash.
So when it came time to do their taxes,
I had a donate all that money back to
them and I paid for the sound system.
I mean,
I treated that place like it was our
place,
you know,
it was a place for comments.
The mix we're cutting out and that
sounds it sounds like practically and
Rogan bought.
It was like fuck it just we got to fix
it.
Line
Shit.
I went and got the top of the line CD
recorders so dudes could make some d's
and I put it all in there out of my own
money because just for love of the club
and then all of a sudden Paulie's
runner.
I'm like,
Nah,
I ain't working for free for you.
You know,
I'll do it all for your mom.
But for you know,
that's who gets the store.
I think he won
for one.
I think his brother gave up.
That's what I heard.
Oh,
his brothers have all the years I've
lived here.
I think I've been in there one time
really?
I've been in that bar area just hanging.
I went with some comments,
but I don't think I've ever been on
stage there.
Walked by yesterday and he was like,
I think I've been here four times and
never.
Career has never really been forming in
Los Angeles.
That's what,
that's what he was like.
I've seen you at the Improv and then I
think I'm,
I think I'm banned from the laugh
factory,
which I.
we're talking about guns and the dude
who owns it to real pacifist.
And Jamie band you for talking about
gun?
Yeah,
that I was on for the next week and then
I got called and said no,
you got called that.
It's a spot called whoever don't like.
So Tamara was so good.
Yeah,
no,
I got asked and then because you talk
about guns,
not sage,
it was all staged conversation.
He's like,
Oh,
what you have gone to me and you want to
kill people?
I'm like,
no,
I enjoyed it.
You have gun?
Yeah,
I have.
I enjoy shooting them,
but if they came into my house then then
I killed him.
What's up?
Jb?
Quit worrying about what comics have in
their house and introducing little kids
and Michael Jackson,
so that's a way bigger problem.
Jamie.
Introducing these children that are on
the make a wish foundation,
but it was a mega list or something like
that.
He was sick.
He was introducing them to Michael
Jackson.
You're saying introducing.
I say pimping,
pimping his genius,
but he doesn't know what the fuck that
ass I spoke.
I don't think that Michael Jackson fuck
those kids because I think where are the
bodies there?
There'll be not just one kitty fucked.
He'd be fucking hundreds.
I think it's probably eight to 10.
I don't think he did.
I.
I think it's much more likely that we
talked about this before.
I think it's much more likely that a
WHO's just completely fucked up and I
was molested when he was a kid and
abused and he grew up in the public eye
and he grew up as a baby and like being
a drug user and just kind of had I
believe in the power of huge rumors and
I think,
what am I terrible in the ass.
Do you believe that one going through
just because of that theory says other
guest that Mikey from life,
Sarah,
because he saw him without his makeup
kill.
Not little rumors tired because his that
lives down the block from.
You made that one.
I didn't even leave your fucking name,
but the rumor that moved rumor traveled
the whole country.
That's a crazy rumor.
Kurt Metzger told me,
he asked a whatever kind of doctor that
he goes,
there's never been any recorded
documentation of any animal up someone's
blood,
but you know the Internet.
See asshole,
that guy's an idiot still at all.
Go to net nanny.
Like,
dude,
you're missing the good sites,
son.
You ain't never seen the eels come out.
That
really weird.
Kept coming out.
I kept thinking was the same one.
That octopus is up.
They're assholes.
There's some shit going into people's
bodies.
If you could think of it.
Did you see the video?
The dude who,
uh,
has been shooting silicone and is dip
for six years.
How delicious.
It looks like someone,
some dude on twitter.
I don't remember your name.
I apologize.
Some dude on twitter said it looked like
a shaved dead rabbit.
I'll throw the link up for you guys
and um,
I will,
uh,
I'll,
we're going to watch it right now,
but I'll throw the link.
Gotcha.
You guys can see it show showing where
they talk about Internet videos.
They played it and it couldn't show
their video.
So they just showed the audience's
reaction,
so they're all just sitting there so
they,
all of them just bought faces.
That's funny.
Okay.
I can't find.
It must have been from a couple of days
ago by tweet too much.
We're on two hours right now.
So what?
We're having a party here.
We're not really on two hours.
We didn't start on time.
It's only 4:00
right now.
Brian,
you fucking faker.
You're saying it like you counted the
time.
We're on two hours.
Four or five.
And second.
That's about two hours.
You took a wild shot.
Completely accurate with the minutes.
Oh good.
I'm trying to find this dead rabbit.
Brian
text.
I renamed them.
It's techie now.
Tech one day and then I.
Yeah,
I agree with Rod.
I believe it,
but that's.
They always say don't focus on his name.
It was one day you don't.
You don't want to change the name of
your cat has already destroyed a
keyboard.
Keyboard.
He hates anything.
Technology.
Okay.
No.
He went up to my keyboard.
I started using my keyboard.
He like ran.
It was like,
what's that noise jumps up and starts
taking his calls and ripping keys.
I'm like,
Ah,
if I get a,
use my camera and if I turn on a camera,
he sees the camera from across the room,
charges me and tries to grab the camera
and like videos and considering giving
it back to the outrageous.
He's a kitten.
That's what they do,
but it's just all terrain coordination.
Maybe that person was just like
killed,
but technology technology killed him.
So he's had.
There's a part of ghost dad to.
Maybe this is made out of technology.
Nice.
Normal Guy Haircut today.
Brian.
By the way,
this is the most normal dude I've ever
seen.
Your hair.
All right.
Here's the.
I just put it up online.
I just put it up online so you guys are
twittered it.
The address of the dude who was
injecting silicone into his dick for six
years and we're going to watch it right
now because it is that fucked up.
It is something to eat and I just
clicked on it right now.
So it's loading up right now.
Check this shit out.
Music,
music,
music.
Feedback in the noise right there.
The worst.
When you have 27 tabs open up and you're
like,
that's so fucking annoying.
What is that?
To find it.
Let's see
where I'm wearing a little intention.
So that's all that.
Why would you want to look at this
to hold it?
Why would you want me to back it up?
Hold on.
Hello?
Would you like to name it though?
Oh,
it was real cocky.
It's funny.
We can't watch Hulu that.
Oh my God,
he's been injecting silicone in it was
dick or six years.
Can we get hard?
Is that all head on topic?
And then they look at it.
So that's all that is.
Hold it.
Should I continue?
Okay.
That's how we're.
Could it be he's injecting silicone into
his fucking.
I mean,
look at that.
That's insane.
Six years of injecting silicon of is six
years.
It's unlikely he's unable to have sex.
I see.
You really think I'd like to fuck his
ass.
I was listening to pleasure.
The adventure and the experience that
I've gotten from this way.
Way,
way better than whatever,
15 minutes of pleasure that I would
guess what is,
what has he gotten experience in this
deck and no longer stand up to pee
because it would just kind of go
everywhere,
you know,
it was difficult to control.
And so I started learning about,
okay,
I have to sit down and I'll tell you
about some other adjustments in the
second play of these adjustments.
So they just add to the excitement for
me because it's just another reminder
and it's part of the Odyssey of,
of all of this,
you know,
so I was sitting down to pee for a long
time.
Well then the size got to be that when I
would sit down,
I'd get wet.
It would get dumped into the water and
toilets concluding my own.
And so I would have sort of squat over
the ball.
You know,
I,
I think that just the fact that people
look at me and either wonder what's
going on,
what is that,
you know,
the basic questions that people ask,
can you still have an orgasm?
Things like that.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm getting people to think and I'm
challenging their ideas of what a
payments should look like,
um,
should,
uh,
function and so challenging.
Giving them a challenge to down the
gauntlet bitch.
The crazy thing is attention.
No.
Would you like to name it though?
I mean,
this guy's like so happy to be pulling
us deck,
looking at us,
touch it,
look at that.
Wasn't even really looking at a penis
and what it really looks like.
Basketball,
the underwear I'm wearing,
he's challenging.
Your perceptions are what the fuck?
I'm getting tired.
I'm not.
He is that dude
there.
Other ways you can challenge people to
think maybe you know,
what is that when dudes like tattooed
their dicks and put barbells through
what's going on there?
They just think presentation,
presentation on a silver platter with
the birth parents that are into that.
Is there a little twitter poll?
How many girls are really into dudes
with like tattoos and barbells and the
same shit with girl.
Put that bar down there and their
vaginas.
How smelly the barbell and the pussy
makes me sad.
I don't really like it,
but I'm not against against.
There's.
Is there a single girl that ever has
gotten a barbell and the slot?
Not Anything wrong with slots.
I don't say slot in a negative way.
I mean a girl that's down to party.
That's what I'll say that instead
though.
I mean there's no proves that gives
their cliff you,
you get your clip periods,
you're sending a message.
Yeah,
because you can't really do this and the
guy would go,
well you,
you're,
you can have a license.
Yeah.
You clearly did.
And the license plates.
So you had that.
That right there says you.
You're in.
You.
Do you feel like your vaginal be so
public?
Yeah,
that you will set up a little bit.
Apparently someone that's from a
documentary on Dick's,
the guy with the fucked up tick from a
documentary.
That'd be a good one to watch.
Take Viagra and try to knock it on the
rush and the entire time you're watching
movies that are like,
no,
just punch himself.
Gave guys give guys like a really high
dose of by Agora and they want me to
watch gay porn and you had girls,
girls touching them.
They were allowed guys massaging your
back.
They give you viagara and extra seat and
then see if you gave the first guy that
you would definitely get art.
Know no question.
A suicide challenge match.
Yeah.
That would be a funny.
I mean we find some Israeli note.
There's no way them games.
You're going to get married.
I don't want that.
You know those that's not right.
Just take to have some guy just blowing
in your ear and see what happens.
To have some really soft boys.
Smells pretty.
Rubbing your back.
Slow.
Long coils and a feminine voice.
Feminine starts getting hard.
Pretty bored.
That's hilarious.
Just whispering and you know,
truck drivers touching yourself.
Sore backs like,
Oh yeah,
right.
Caught it right there.
Okay,
we'll fix it.
We'll fix you up.
No worries.
I heard Bobby Kelly talking about this
on Tuesday,
but like why?
That was even insult.
Why faggots even that,
like they've never done anything to me.
Why is that?
Like your technical amount,
I'll fight you to prove that I'm on.
I was like,
what is the difference for like,
yeah,
if you get the little thing with some
guys touching me with whatever I don't
like when people touch me because of
dudes are thinking about fucking mean.
I know how I am.
When I think about fucking girls and I
don't want anybody thinking about me
like that.
They,
you know when,
if you want to fuck somebody like you,
you,
you're,
you know,
you're like,
you're into them,
you're going after I'm doing that to
you.
It doesn't want to listen to the fact
that you're straight like,
hey,
I don't like that.
And then it keeps going after you.
That's like disturbing.
Yeah.
I mean,
the first time I've never tried to go
after a check,
like the most clumsy and your history.
Could you imagine someone doing that to
you?
A guy doing it to you,
like you're drunk and stupid and master
that do do that to you.
You feel so uncomfortable and gross and
negative.
Oh,
you're ranked.
Find Intelligence.
Always do that.
They will creep up.
Dudes.
Here we get aggressively homosexual.
When guys get trumped,
they get crazy.
If I was kissing another one of our
friends,
he's like
kiss.
It was like calm down.
What was that guy's named Jason
something or another.
He was lured flambeau.
Really?
Flamboyantly gay.
Any would get aggressive who's a content
and we were all in Montreal.
It was like four or five of us.
I don't remember who was talking to.
I think Bobby Slayton I think was one of
them,
but he came over and it was like the end
of the night and he was like,
you know,
I'm stuck in someone's dead because it's
going to be yours.
I'm like,
man,
get the fuck out of here.
I should find a gay dude for straight
dudes.
I mean think about an artist for a
straight guy to get laid and then
thinking about how hard it is for a good
guy to get laid.
Like their numbers are low but such a
higher percentage when you find the
rumors.
Yeah.
If you go to like,
you know,
boys town or something to go to Santa
Monica Boulevard.
Yeah.
You're going to get a lot there,
but if you're in thousand oaks looking
for gay sex,
that's tough actually.
You know,
you've got to find them.
You got to go there,
church,
got to do something.
You got to figure out how it was in the
army.
And they're like
forties and fifties and sixties where
people grew up in small towns had never
seen.
They just thought they were weird
because feelings,
but they didn't know the ones that grew
up in New York and La obviously they
knew about gay so much.
And then they go to the army and all of
a sudden they find other gays and they
find each other and say,
oh,
well,
that's like a real problem.
Especially in the navy when dudes were
on boats,
there was a dude,
uh,
that,
we knew that was going away to the navy.
His little brother was going away,
the navy,
we're all sitting around eating with
them.
And I just,
as a joke,
I said,
man,
you need to learn some Jujitsu.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you could fight off the rape on the boat
race.
And he goes,
yeah man,
fucking fucked up man.
That shit happens.
I go,
what do you mean it happens?
Like that dude's really raped.
It was in the boats.
He goes,
well,
you know,
it's not that big a deal.
It's not that big a deal.
He goes,
well,
I've been in for a year.
I only know four dudes.
What?
You know for dudes who had been raped by
men and you've only been in the navy for
a fucking year,
could you imagine if you knew for
Commerce to get raped?
He likes comedy.
If somebody started raping UFC
commentators and I'm going to watch that
shit from my house,
fucking guns in my lap.
Fuck you.
What?
Are you crazy?
He was only in the navy a year with that
and it happened here or he during that
year,
he knew.
Wow.
Four dudes who says,
wow.
I mean,
how many people was he coming in contact
with?
Even though the navy's gigantic.
That's,
that's a big number.
If it's a few thousand still.
Fuck.
You ever come close to join the military
or anything?
Yeah.
I had a a recruiter show up at the
grocery store.
I work
that.
It was air force.
I thought of it,
went to my high school and then I
remember him.
How old is that?
Like 17,
18,
and then when I
wrestled in high school,
then he lists,
recruit on,
forget,
saw our heavyweight and goes,
yeah,
as I'm looking for John have friend and
then this guy started laughing.
He's like,
he's too small because when I was in
high school I was going to be five slash
600.
I think I rustled the 105 pounds,
so I didn't grow until after like three
years old.
I just want to fall in a real way.
What I wrestled.
I know,
right?
100,
five pounds of jail.
You're pretty small.
Yeah,
it's fuck John.
He on problems.
I would have to see the picture would
have been.
Were you thinking about joining the
military?
Same time.
17,
19 and it was kind of interesting.
Instead of college,
they're like,
fuck that shit.
Yeah.
I was going to go for college,
like in National Guard is like you can
get some cones during a flood or
something.
Really wonderful.
Do you remember the date that's the Bush
administration change all that bullshit.
The national guard used to be a safe way
to not go to war and you're helping
people.
You're still in college of duty and they
split families up and it's rough.
We'll even look.
If you look at Rambo,
my bro was all national guard guys want
to have to ramble.
The whole movie was making fun of these
national guard guys like to do anything.
I got to get back to the store and now
the national guard guys are as bad as
soon as anyone else.
Dude I
digital with and he was in the army
reserve for 20 years and 20 days left in
his 20 year tour.
Twenty years,
20 days left.
They sent him to Iraq for a year and a
half,
so if they start before the term was
over,
just lock you in.
It doesn't matter and they can bring you
back.
They can bring you back anytime they
want.
They recall you.
They're hurting so bad nowadays.
I'm surprised they're not just like,
oh,
you're an eagle scout.
You got pop in Iraq.
A lot of dudes who go over there because
they think they're doing the right
thing.
There's a lot of dudes like Pat Tillman
due to join the army and joined the
navy.
They think they're doing it to protect
this great
countries.
Especially then in like 2001,
2002 people who wants that.
Yeah.
And then realize you're getting fucked.
And that's what happened with Pat
Tillman mean he was a huge critic as was
his brother of,
of how fucked up things are over in Iraq
and Afghanistan and,
and you know,
obviously wanting to kill him,
kill the friendly fire.
I remember a year ago I went and did a
show and it got back to hoax tell and I
googled oldest age and joined the army.
I was like,
I'm going to be old as fuck right now.
I bumped it up 42,
40 2:43,
but that's like 20 years longer than
that.
Would you be listed there or no,
you do it and we'll start this officer
corps or what was it?
A couple of things.
One,
they would say I joined it,
you know,
40.
They give me a job that intake a 19 year
old out of that job in the of that 19
year old on this line.
So like the older guys is like.
But I know one of my wife's friends,
she's in a,
she's an airborne ranger.
She said she has privates in her thing
that are like 30,
30,
eight years old.
Do you know just guys that are.
I have no fucking money and they don't
have anything in their town and there's
no option to do.
What's the difference?
He
for the rest of the major problem I'm
talking about in general,
it's like war for eight years,
dude.
Yeah,
we've been at war for eight years.
Man,
I joined the military for the last
decade.
Has Been No joke,
you know,
it's just what the fuck man.
It's when I was a kid.
Vietnam ended when I was a little boy
and I remember thinking very clearly
that all this is a good thing because
now there's not gonna be any more war to
like obviously everybody hates war and
you're never gonna go to war again and
then when I was like 21 was the first
Gulf war,
me and my buddy Jimmy did Telia we're
sitting,
we had an apartment together and
Waltham,
Massachusetts.
It was ethnic guineas hanging out wall
and we're sitting in front of the TV and
the fucking the first trial to happen
and they showed the missiles coming in
and bombs going off and I was like,
Holy Shit.
And we,
me and Jimmy wash it like we were
watching a football game here.
We're like,
dude,
we're at war.
Shit.
I remember being in college.
Then the two guys I lived with are all
reservists and then they got called up,
so they were probably 20,
21 years old.
Twenty two got called up and went down
to.
They were going to start to help train.
At the time everybody was like,
just give me a draft.
There's gonna be a draft.
So we all thought because we were that
at that age we were 20,
21.
We're like,
holy crap,
we're going.
There was a serious.
Yeah.
So scary man.
I remember when the first Gulf War
happened,
we're practicing basketball and it was
the opening night of some play,
some high school player and somebody
came in and like the play bomb,
the plane,
the plane's bond.
But I just learned to play bombed while
you're breaking up our practice for the.
So I'm a little happy about it.
The whole thing.
So surreal.
I got woken up,
I don't remember who woke me up,
but somebody called me and told me that
Americans are Americans under attack and
I was like,
why turn the news?
America is under attack and we just are
so removed from all this shit and it
goes on and the rest of the world we are
so removed from what war really is.
Unless you've talked to someone who's
actually been over there and come back
and they have a very different opinion
of it,
but we're so fucking removed from it
over here.
When I saw that shit on tv,
I was like,
what?
Really?
Like,
this isn't a movie.
It was like your heart starts beating
faster.
It's like all of a sudden this team
you're on is under attack,
you know?
I mean,
it's not you,
but it's like we're all in this team
together and then you don't think about
that three a day to day life.
You can say you're happy to be an
American shit and you believe in
democracy and I'm Republican,
but you don't really realize you're on
some team until teams attack and then
you're like,
so that did nothing due to didn't know
these dudes came over and killed them.
Just because they were living on this
spark.
They were living in this patch of dirt
so people were killing him.
That's it.
I thought that was the only movie shit.
My brother's over there now is he just
got called up again.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's what happens when you,
when you go through a tour,
if you sign up for the military,
Dick Cheney instituted some new
situation where they can just kind of
keep bringing you back when they still
an active reserve,
so he knows eventually got called up
again,
but when they were in a situation where
people floors and they were bringing
them back.
Yeah.
Ugh.
Randall Masker,
how long are you going to ask the same
question over and over and over again.
Some dude ask him a question over and
over again.
I've seen it 10 times more women by you
reading it.
Are we rewarding him?
So yeah,
when people ignore you,
sometimes you ever make a joke like in
public and nobody laughs and then you
hear somebody like make the same job
again because I assumed nobody heard
them look at their response and fucking
take that to me and they didn't find it
funny.
The worse,
and someone thinks you weren't listening
and they say it again.
What that means.
It's not in the moment trying to make
this job.
There's all the branches other than the
army are overloaded.
Actually believed that.
Now,
now I think he's probably telling the
truth.
I would think that in this economy I
would say was a lot.
Yeah.
A lot of people.
It is a lot higher than
look at what was it,
how long?
Two years ago,
New Orleans,
you know,
we didn't have enough people to send
their two years ago,
isn't it?
Was that a lot more than two years ago?
When was Katrina?
What year was that?
I mean it wasn't longer
because that was when I first heard
about Kanye West.
Hi.
My favorite was Michael Myers.
Reaction because he's just a Hollywood
guy.
I do not want to be associated with.
It was just so uncomfortable.
I know he.
He got so.
I mean that was like one of the blackest
dangerous things.
Like why am I in this picture?
Bush is not like black people.
Judge hates black people.
You say hates her.
Does not.
Like George Bush.
Hates,
hates,
hates black people.
Yeah.
Why is that guy still on TV?
Now?
He's on tv because he's a douchebag and
because people are looking for him to do
something wrong.
His like his TV has evolved.
It used to be like,
here's this young artist,
now it's like this guy is such a cock,
like having close to the calcium was
stupid and I hate them and it will get
you a million hits on Youtube.
When he took the microphone away from
that girl,
he'll be hated forever.
You don't do that.
What was even worse with this fake
apology on Leno later trying to work up
tears,
but he couldn't quite do it.
Oh,
he's so,
so weak and it was just saying it's
going to take a step back and he's not
going to work on some show.
He's got one.
She just shut the fuck up.
The my favorite is when he says,
just please just let me be great.
Just let me be great.
George Bush doesn't care about black
people's hair.
That's what I thought it was.
Thank you.
Aren't an adder boy.
Yeah.
Hate is a strong word.
I hate my mic.
Mike Myers.
Flinch at pA.
little,
little dribble go.
This could ruin my career.
What happened to that dude?
Mike Meyers.
Yeah.
They're actually making a new Austin
powers movie.
Awful.
That last movie was death scene up,
put them in,
put them in and glorious bastards was
horrible.
It was so like,
why is this?
Because it wasn't being funny.
So then it's like,
why would you put clearly someone who's
known as a comedic actor?
He gave me the wrong way.
You're doing the same movie,
but,
but it's an Indian American Eczema.
It wasn't bad because it wasn't just
like a little bit like
I never saw that.
It was a great movie two years ago.
Uh,
people are asking you to take us to take
a break.
Why?
Because we'd been on straight for
awhile.
What does that mean?
They can't leave the fucking screen
breaks and I go to the bathroom when get
up.
We're done.
We're done at 4:30
and I have to do some sort of an
interview with some people in Australia
for a Gig.
I'm doing an Australia just a lot trying
to drop names and Australia checking it
into national style.
Like my boss,
Soulja boy happened to that guy.
This is a knife guy.
Oh No.
God.
As famous as what's possible for him.
He was huge for someone just made a
reference.
Paul Hogan.
Right.
Is that a guy,
a family guy or sense?
It just made a reference about him
because I want to get hugely famous
African crocodile hunter and that
knocked it up and.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and then not famous at all like that.
Yeah.
How weird is that?
God was doing movies and shit.
There was millions and left Hollywood.
We got sick of him as I think people
just to crocodiles ids and then that
didn't try to like be in someone else's
film.
Yeah,
and we didn't see him in a romantic
comedy or crocodile guy.
Must've lost some money
movie and said fuck him.
Have you seen the preview for the new
Mcgregor Mcgregor?
But you may have a whole movie coming
out and usually SNL macgyver,
but groover macgruber.
It's taken me on Saturday night live
making a movie and they get a new
preview.
That's about that just came out and the
funny thing about snl movies is that
they usually always have the best parts
in the preview.
There is not one part in this was fun.
It looks good.
It's,
it's bad as the word when go to a
preview
and you just sit there and go,
oh,
what the fuck are they doing?
Like why would someone like promote
this?
There's nothing worse than bad comment
because at least bad drum was hilarious.
Bad drama like showgirls or something
like that.
Those are genuinely funny movies.
You know,
I got some left behinds there,
there.
The,
the,
the uh,
rapture videos that,
that fucking dude makes the shit.
Are they awesome?
They're so good.
They're so beautifully stupid.
Why concur?
Cameron get owned on Youtube is one of
my favorite past times.
He's so dumb.
I just thought.
Did you really the one where he's on the
debate team.
I don't remember what it was,
but it was like a group date of labor
and a few other people.
We got driven.
They're found.
I had her license.
Yeah,
it was a debate and I remember the big
climax at the end was like,
because some teacher taught them in the
clear move to the rest of the movie that
he sounded like he was being real,
but he really wasn't.
And then later was like,
you serious about that?
It was Kirk Cameron loves the COC,
a guarantee that he loves the cock.
There's no doubt about it.
There's no way.
He's that crazy.
Gung Ho Jesus.
The rapture,
no sin,
no masturbation.
Exhaust fucking gay as the day as you
know,
with every fiber of his being trying to
stay on the straight and narrow and
liked girls.
And meanwhile he just wants to fucking
cock cock mouth.
Herschel Walker was talking about when
you were doing his fight.
Strikeforce.
And he said he doesn't a master bath.
Yeah,
but he's crazy.
Herschel Walker Scott like split
personality disorder.
He was hurt.
He was trauma related.
I thought it was trauma related.
He said his heisman trophy,
like he's got all these different.
Think about how many times I got.
Must've had concussions.
I don't know if he's a big guy though.
He plays football.
Everybody gets concussions playing
football right now,
a quarterback who's had the most simple
like ever,
but that's coordinated.
Blindside hits all the time.
She was standing there with my fucking
crushed them helmet the helmet.
But anytime you get hit,
even if you're not getting a concussion,
it's a little bit of getting fucking
rattled.
Even if you get up and you get back up
when you get smashed into by some giant
dude who's a full clip,
even if you don't go out and either if
you don't have a concussion where like
your,
your pupils are dilated,
you got some brain damage,
son,
you just got jarred,
you know,
that's,
that's reality.
And when you do that shit over and over
and over again,
football is one of the most
rothenberger last week and that would
have been about this burger.
Was there a big quarterback,
whoever it was like,
oh,
Kurt Warner,
who threw an interception of what's the
neck tackle?
And then he just got blindsided.
You see them on the ground with the
train is over him and he's like talking,
but you can clearly see he's not making
any sense.
He was like,
no,
I'm on the end.
You're like,
that's nuts.
That happens a lot.
Wonky caching once bought a a gang
banger.
He hit me in the back of the head.
We were sparring in and I kind of went
down,
but he said it was the slowest knockout
ever.
Like I went to one knee and he goes,
are you okay?
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm good.
And then I went to the other night.
He's fine.
I'm just kinda like,
literally,
I'm just gonna I'm gonna lay here for a
second.
Do we have time if I could lay here?
That's what I'm saying to them.
Long story short,
that a girlfriend I was dating at the
time came to my apartment,
goes,
you bought a VCR and I go,
no,
she goes to,
there's a best buy with a VCR thing over
there.
Who's is it?
Go over.
It's my signature,
um,
bought.
This is back when dvds though.
So like I even want the older VCR and I
bought it from the way home after I left
the place,
I didn't realize bought it
and then she goes,
what's the matter with you or whatever.
And I go,
wow,
spawn and die.
And then she's like,
he looked and then we went to the uh,
doctors and then I lifted up a foot and
then the whole thing.
Yeah,
that sounds like a state of when you
wake up and someone's like,
well,
there's no football players.
They said data.
Remember,
like trike would say he would play a
whole corridor and didn't remember
playing the whole
Joe Dirks fighter such fuck Patrick
Kotsay.
And it was an awesome fight.
Patch coats.
I caught him with big shot Dirksen and
Dirksen wind up taking his back and
choking him out.
It was fucking chaos.
Great fight.
And I ran into Dirksen after the fight.
We were on the way the press was like,
oh dude,
that was fucking awesome.
Find what a come from behind victory.
He goes,
I don't remember it.
Know you don't remember.
What happened was,
oh man,
he cracked me.
I don't remember what happened.
I didn't get this back,
but this wasn't even an interview.
That was just me and him backstage.
I got his back and you get the,
the Bj Penn.
You hold the hook over the arm,
the arm,
and he choked them out.
I go,
it's beautiful,
man.
Wait till You see it.
he's got.
I don't remember it.
Wow.
Because I don't remember that number.
I thought it was a joke.
He was like,
oh,
I know.
I don't remember this at all.
Is that a good hole?
A miller against dan lozano.
he got,
he got dropped and he will be thinking
how bad that we heard when you got to
try because I got dropped.
He didn't.
Oh wow.
I did like,
his reaction was so real.
Tim sylvia,
when he fought,
um,
uh,
what's his name?
randy coture.
When tim silvia got cracked in the first
round,
he woke up going into the fourth round.
He didn't know around was he thought the
second one was the fourth round or we
saw the fourth round was the second
round.
Was off by three.
missed fifth.
I think it might've been the fifth
because he told them like,
this is the last round.
I was like,
what the last round,
like he thought it was like the second
round,
like he was gone to race.
He was founded on autopilot.
Just your body trying not to die.
Do you know just get rid of nerves is
just randomly scrolling.
Blasted.
I love like striking training.
I love hitting the pad and hitting the
bag and sparring with somebody you can
trust is fun.
If you can find that guy that knows 70
percent is 70 percent.
You're 17 months you in the face
recently in your car?
Yeah,
same thing.
That's why I like,
I like,
I enjoy drinking.
Like you say we're doing literally I go,
let's go 40 percent because I got too
much
and if you got people don't know when
you do like striking spawn,
the whole deal is that you don't hit
each other hard.
You like,
you hit each other like a little bit but
you don't try to knock it out.
And so I'm like,
and my problem is is I don't get in
close enough.
So I told the guy let's go 40.
That way if I do get drilled right in
the face,
it's not going to,
so then I throw a kick,
but I'm throwing a kick at 40 percent,
which means any little kid could grab
that kid.
It's not going fast,
so he swoops it,
grabs it,
and then blast hunches as as hard as he
could after after catches my foot and
then I'm just laying there and I went,
yeah,
that's what I'm going to do more jujitsu
because the worst thing that's going to
happen to me,
if somebody is going to tap me out.
I mean that could be that weird
occasionally,
but it's more of a not a gentleman's
sport.
It's just a.
When the worst thing that's happened is
that I go like that and I'm not going,
man.
I already just weird playing where let's
slow down.
Good guys don't hurt you.
Good guys are the least worried about
like,
well,
the guy like eddie,
if he gets your arm,
he's going to have full control.
He's not going to pull it back and snap
it.
You got to worry about them.
Strong blue belts that are just startIng
to learn how to tap people.
Those are the ones that you know or you
know,
like just real hyper aggressive and they
don't know how to relax yet or it's
super powerful.
White belts who just learning moves the
most.
bruises all over your fucking
bar.
Somebody especially like if I find a
place wherever I'm performing,
that's a better story
for them is getting knocked out.
That comment that that's a Way better
story.
Then to tell what to work on getting
inside.
Do you mind if I.
I'm going to Be some places that you go
to or not.
People don't try to do that at all.
Like when I went to a mall easton's
place In boulder when I moved there and
I started training their people couldn't
have been nicer.
Yeah,
everybody was cool.
There was no assholes.
There was no agro dues,
no one trying to tap,
you know,
one getting crazy.
I mean they were trying to tap you,
but they weren't trying to rush.
You know?
They were just rolling.
It was all from how cool the
instructors,
the instructors.
Cool.
That the people that quit like eddie so
friendly and so relaxed and so cool to
everybody that everybody in the whole
gym carries that friendly,
relaxed attitude.
You know,
you go to like john jocks,
the same thing.
John xoxo are real nice guy so everybody
there is nice but it was so hard to just
start talking and you want to hit it and
then I was like,
I wonder if people laugh.
They're gone.
You got so hIgh.
I spent the first five minutes of class
talking about some history channel
documentary on a ufo.
The first five minutes they got
scientists,
man
pulling up
to channel.
Shit's going down.
I'm like,
how high are you right now?
How often do you do digital?
Once wants to one point five times a
week.
I mean even that,
once you get your thinking about it,
I just get so mad at myself.
Like I'll go on stuff and then you come
back and you just hope somebody gone.
I used to remember sometHing I don't
remember today and then try to hold the
water.
You've got to just be like ron,
four weeks off,
and they tried to your act like,
how does thIs go?
You don't even remember your bets.
You have to review your recordings.
I forgot to shit.
Then I took an extended period off and I
forgot to shit and I was like,
well,
I can do something here.
I don't have any idea.
You forget a lot of shit.
I forgot completely forgot how to do
this.
This,
this move to break the arm bar.
That was called the silverado.
It's my favorite move and I was a purple
belt.
I completely forgot about it.
Reviewing it the other night.
I'm like,
oh yeah,
that's how it goes in.
You know,
I,
I forgot how to do it,
but it was like one of my favorite
moves.
It's weird.
Jujitsu.
There's so many moves.
That's the crazy thing about it is
it's different.
Do you think it's not matched right?
You think a year from now some guy would
do.
Something comes off a lot,
people are doing offers based on what
you do,
but then no one has ever thought to
defend this move yet because it hasn't
been.
Once it does get invented,
then you've got to have a counter.
There's this new move they're dudes have
been doing real recently called the
japanese necktie and it's just come out
like I think it was the first person to
do it and in the program,
yeah,
it's japanese neck ties,
like a sort of like a darce,
but you,
you,
you grab it,
you grab it with a gable grip,
but he turned the guy's head up towards
his chest and you have your chest pinned
on them.
It's fucking nasty.
It's like,
how does no one know this before?
We're in this position all the time.
They try to get the doors,
cho,
but it really.
There's,
there's an even better job.
This right there.
So as soon as you lock up that gable
grip and you get on top of guy,
you tuck it under and you're bending his
fucking neck towards his chest.
Your chest is on top of his head.
He's got no air,
no blood.
Whenever I do those drills and it's
crying,
oh,
I always pretend like we have an odd
number of people in the class.
I don't know.
You shouldn't do it now.
Yeah,
but you do it anyway.
You got to relax.
Just let him,
let him yanked your neck around.
It's such a small difference between
fine and a serious pain.
Yeah,
but you got to get used to that and no
one's going to hurt you doing that,
you know,
but it's going to be uncomfortable.
But that,
that moves.
It's so important to learn how,
where,
where it comes on because like the
japanese necktie comes on so quick
peruvian guy to.
It's like,
you're going like this and then you're
just jumping back and hopefully you
don't go too far.
It's a spazzy move.
Awesome.
Of peruvian necktie and japanese
necktie.
Both of them are the shit they fucked
you up,
man.
That's a terrible position to be in.
I think the japanese neckties even mom
peruvians.
Pretty bad ass to the proven you've got
your weight on top of him.
Always the japanese necktie.
You kinda like on the side and hooking
it,
but it doesn't it so good.
Such a powerful move like that.
Oh,
I think we're done.
Do you rebrand the japanese people?
I'm like,
hAve I ever seen a japanese guy wearing
it?
Well,
what about that fucking japanese video
gaMe?
That video that you posted and we should
end with that because that is the most
bizarre fucking thing I think I've ever
seen on the internet and sheets.
There's some crazy japanese video game
that's like these two musclebound gay
guys were in diapers and there there are
human bicycle and they're riding on the
road and they're getting chased and I
mean it is one of the weirDest things
and these Lead that lead the league in
weirdness.
So strange.
Do you know if people don't know?
There's like you can go to vending
machines in Japan.
You can buy used panties.
Like that's real.
Yeah.
You go places.
They sell used panties going,
wait,
why couldn't we up in one of those
there?
Because you have one out here and just
to do is get a girl.
Let's put it on real quick.
Throw in a bag and I think you have to
have enough people that you can.
You'd have different levels.
One,
the girl wears it all day.
That's the primo.
She doesn't change her panties all day.
No shower in the morning.
She goes to the gym.
I can you get those stinky,
sweaty,
funky moose knuckle underwears.
I think you've missed an opportunity for
the uh,
and joe rogan a fanny pack.
I'm going to make a line and I was
thinking about your fashion show.
I'm making fanny packs and then used
panties.
Rogaine.
I mean you can probably get it.
So instead of expanding packets.
Oh,
you weren't a role.
I mean there's some huge.
Yeah,
like goals and just sick.
I'm kidding about the fanny pack thing.
You see me at the airport.
I always had one else thinks you should
shape a fanny pack.
Like a skull,
like a three dimensional sculpture can
get a little crazy with it.
It doesn't.
It's overhead compartment for your junk,
you know,
you're saying the sky's the limit.
Really useful feedbacks.
THe shit got fighters entering.
Would that be a little bit of a thing?
But you're sponsored by question and
after seeing the jew clam,
what's going to shock us?
We're going to show you.
It's not as shocking as the jew by
everybody actually.
Funny.
So ours clean your will.
Turn off the webcam now and check it
out.
Alright.
Thank you very much ladies and gentleman
for another fun,
fun use three podcasts.
I hope you enjoyed it.
John heffron needs more twitter
followers.
People,
john [inaudible].
Have fun with two f's and we love you.
Bitches strong.
Alright guys.
Thanks for watching.